[Musique]
que c'est beau
ou quand le
je salue cette envie de gagner cette
envie de cogner
que c'est beau d'exister comme un air du
monde d'avant au programme du concert
test d'hier soir à bercy
le groupe indochine mélanie maintenant
que tu es bien installée à côtés d'agnès
les spectateurs masqué testés et tous
négatifs avaient entre 18 et 45 ans les
scientifiques ont observé à l'aide de
caméras
si les masques étaient correctement
portée donc là je porte mon bac j'ai
envers mon masque passe en dessous du
nez je vais ange half masque c'est à
dire qu'on ne masque est moyennement
porte et je fus de masques je vais en
rouge c'est du totalitarisme c'est aux
téléspectateurs fin j'attendais j'ai
quelques questions vous avez qu'alex
goude nos jeunes et parce que j'attends
j'attends de voir je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas pressé je fais
mon libre arbitre et je viserai
rassemble effectivement par les remords
de ces vaccins là je suis le smile
rigolard et on le préférait des adultes
est le plus utilisé et je lui préfère la
tête de mort pour mort de rire
après tout l'essentiel c'est d'être
qu'on prépare son groupe dans des
cimetières pareil ça me déprime un peu
donc franchement rien à [ __ ] ça
m'apporte plus rien tennis de heureux
quand on voit les conditions les truffes
à se retrouver ici c'est d'une tristesse
absolue alors que d'habitude c'est le
meilleur tournoi du monde
donc franchement rien à [ __ ] et je
vais rentrer chez moi de vous
certains oui d'observer si c'est vous
qui l'avez mais en restant vous savez
l'ancien si le vaccin soigne quoi qu'il
arrive je vous suis désolé d'abord ça ce
jeune élu a dit sa bombe mais pas
n'importe quoi jésus a dit ça ne vous
énervez pas si je m'énervais part j'en
ai marre ça me donne le cas c'est les
rois des tombes tu veux pas de ce qu'on
peut réduire un peu le retour des plaies
des merdes chaque célibataire peut
maintenant indiqué qu'il est vacciné et
aussitôt l'algorithme de l'application
va le favoriser
pour réaliser plus de rencontres
visiblement ça intéresse du monde
pour moi qui suis sur un site de
rencontres c'est pas une mauvaise idée
la vaccination c'est sexy taxes et vous
si vous étiez un homme le temps d'une
journée
aubin le truc classique quoi
pas je crois que j'arrêterais pages de
toucher ce sexe je crois que je serai
toutes les expériences possibles et
inimaginables drogué draguer vous l'avez
été oui comme tout le monde ici dans ce
métier ça je peux pas accepter ça donc
pas comme tout le monde dans ce métier
comme peut-être ceux qui sortent la nuit
tous les atouts les bains bref tout
c'est un passage obligé sur la vous vous
trompez on peut demander à plein de gens
aussi sur ce plateau je pense pas qu'on
soit tous drogués dans le monde
ah bon il n'y avait pas d'héroïne
maintenant notre héroïne est là il ya
quelqu'un qui a faim de ce qui est juste
derrière si vous faites dont vous allez
voir et vous allez voir
[Musique]
tous les partis flamands que nos manus
comme ginjfo des hawks frigide et nous
on casse zidane où il avait 17 ans
voulait pas vous mettre la ce a donné l'
oblige même taper si c'est mieux venez
là et vous allez danser la pub ni la
même si vous êtes chiche voilà vous
allez peut-être voilà alors je préviens
alors je vais dire je préviens c'est
rien là voilà le nouveau présentateur d
prévoit la peine de mort selon michael
et jennifer c'est une excellent buteur
d'entre vous se demandent quel est
l'objet le plus moche et tu sors une
photo avec booder ouais c'est ça jardim
[Musique]
et il est finalement dérouté vers minsk
en plein vol alors officiellement c'est
à cause d'une alerte à la bombe nous dit
le président biélorusse en réalité et on
la prend très vite c'est pour
interpeller le journaliste dissident
romane protasiewicz est ce qu'il ya des
pays malgré tout qu'ils ont réussi à se
mettre à l'écart de cette religion des
droits de l'homme ou qui s'en sont
séparés mais singulièrement des pays
européens est ce qu'il y ait s'il ya des
exemples que l'on pourra suivre déjà
comment à c'est la démocratie par
excellence la néo qu'ancienne vetiq
l'antique démocratie helvétique le
modèle de la démocratie dont le peuple
souverain qui n'a plus le droit à la
parole en france dont le peuple
souverain a décidé de créer un article
constitutionnel qui interdit la
construction de minarets
cette maladie de la haine qui fait que
certains en viennent même à critiquer
ceux qui sont sur des navires par les
mers démontées pour aller sauver des
enfants qui se noie et qui dit vous
inciter à l'immigration est ce que vous
vous rendez compte du degré de perte
d'humanité quand on arrête quand on
arrive à ressentir ça
il ne restera pas non plus grand chose
de ce porte conteneurs depuis huit jours
ils brûlent au large du sri lanka et
risque de provoquer une marée noire
nous en bus la planète
or et mac os
d'ores et déjà les plages sont souillés
par des billes de plastique provenant de
la cargaison du navire sur 28 conteneurs
8 sont tombés à l'eau les militaires ou
le voyez s'emploie à nettoyer les côtes
22 blanc blond
il n'y a pas de couleur blanche le coup
tu peux regarder au bon endroit
alors je crois comprendre à redon vous
avez regardé la couleur le nombre de pas
c'est la couleur d'à côté perdez pas une
minute
[ __ ] con et puis regardez ces images
impressionnantes là encore au large de
l'indonésie là c'est un grand ferry qui
a pris feu ça s'est passé tôt ce matin
il y avait près de 200 personnes à bord
les passagers et l'équipage ont dû se
jeter à la mer
la croisière s'amuse love boat est
orpheline aujourd'hui
gavin mcleod alias le capitaine stubing
est décédé hier à l'âge de 90 ans
non vous regarder la caméra et elle dit
on revient après une pause de deux ans
revient on s'engueule on débat on parle
de trucs qu'on connaît pas après la pub